Сьогодні ми маємо усвідомлювати що
єдність є запорукою нашої Перемоги
справжня
недекларативна відкинути політичні
інтриги атаки на ЗСУ атаки на українську
опозицію а об'єднатись бо тільки так
можливо перемогти Сьогодні ми маємо
проявляти стійкість і наші збройні сили
України цю стійкість покажують кожного
дня на фронті ми маємо відповідати
висоті поставлених завдань
на Майдані ми говорили стоїмо до
перемоги Сьогодні ми кажемо боремось до
перемоги тому що наша справа - це справа
наших дідів і прадідів і ця боротьба
заради наших дітей і внуків наша справа
священна і Я впевнений Ми переможемо
Слава Україні Героям слава Андрію лович
дякую